Blake Shelton you know him well and of
course his beautiful girlfriend Gwen
Stefani is it still girlfriend today I
just want to go there the magazine's
this morning I don't know I we spent a
lot of time on Entertainment Tonight
talking about you too but are you
excited because I heard that you heard
God country God's country for the first
time while you were mowing and I'll run
with that it's it was just one of those
moments I was actually you know out on
the land and working and hearing that
song for the first time was just like a
it was like a just out-of-body
experience you know and I knew it it was
important to me and and kinda made a you
know a pact with myself that I am moving
forward I'm just gonna record music that
that I love and yeah let the cards fall
where they may and so here we are I
guess you did a duet with somebody you
love and that for the first time right
this is absolutely mind-blowing I mean
the whole thing it's just like it's hard
to believe that I'm back at the Grammys
but not just that but with Blake Shelton
that's like my favorite human being I
get to do favorite human being
honestly let me ask you how is Blake
helped you my entire life like Adam not
only just everyone was like how was your
drive over it's like wonderful I was
with Blake Shelton like he just makes me
laugh and smile and just it's just like
the greatest guy everybody does it I
mean it's not just me I mean how do you
not be here now do you not put a ring on
that woman's finger I'm just throwing
that out there that's just me that was
like mr. t look that cannot wait for
your performance tonight
good luck tonight well I already lost
motion at aghori we did a pre tail so if
you're cool with it I'm just gonna take
that one
thank you guys thank you right here on
CBS
let's see who else is on the car on the
car you want to get one going with three
it's fine oh no you don't
[Music]